Okay we're almost through
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my full Rick and Morty season six episode seven
video there were a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references in fact there were a lot of jokes
about Rick and Morty being So Meta having so many
jokes and so many references if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the episodes there are going to be 10 episodes
in season six they just went on a brief Hiatus
between episode 6 and episode 7 which they also
referenced during the episode careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet we'll start at
the beginning and work our way through shot by
shot talking about Easter eggs WTF moments and
there were a lot starting with the episode titled
full meta Jack Rick which is a reference to the
Stanley Kubrick movie Full Metal Jacket great
movie if you haven't seen it the meta being a
specific reference to the way that the plot of the
episode plays on a lot of Storytelling tropes in
writer's rooms like the previously on segment of
TV shows and a lot of the episode was the writers
of the show making fun of themselves a lot at the
end of the episode was Dan Harmon making fun of
himself like one of the characters in the episode
was literally a parody of Dan Harmon this isn't
what it looks like this is a very special diet
for successful Riders the actual opening scene
starts with the previously on because of the real
life breaking the episodes between six and seven
recently there's been a break for the last several
weeks so typically shows would have a previously
on just to catch people up who haven't remembered
what happened previously which they reveal in
this context is actually being controlled by
the villain previous Leon who's a being who
has the ability to trap people in previously on
Loops of their lives but they also reveal that
there are fictional things happening within those
previously on Loops so even though it seems like
all the crazy things that happened during their
previously on at the beginning of the episode
some of them are meant to be fake one of the other
long-running tropes of Rick and Morty is that each
season they have a brand new intro scene with
a bunch of different scenes and us as fans are
always trying to guess which scenes are real and
which are fake which is literally what they're
experiencing in this part of the episode the
episode just in general also plays into the idea
that Rick has always known that he's a fictional
character inside a TV show which Morty almost
finds out like it gets most of the way there
until Rick tries to to get him to forget about it
he starts to figure out what's going on during
the Jack the Ripper segment from the season six
intro new dialogue we're marking on it summer
reveals she's pregnant at her 18th birthday
party just like Beth got pregnant with summer when
she was 18 and still in high school it's raining
meatballs for some reason Rick starts to get a
little more worried as they keep jumping through
different events Jerry dies from bee stings
paying off the joke about him keeping bees
all these previous seasons summer names for baby
Jerry Jr they have a cameo scene with Tony Hawk
and his skateboard who's apparently solving murder
mysteries with Rick and Morty it's not actual Tony
Hawk in a cameo scene though it's like a different
voice actor just playing Tony Hawk Rick tries to
hijack the reality M Night shama aliens style the
same kind of thing happened in that episode where
he tried to do something ridiculous to break the
reality when he says narrative decelerant that's
him saying that what he's doing slows down
the story itself they keep jumping through
events Beth is Being Framed executed for Jerry's
death I think that's also meant to be a reference
to the long-running joke about how she has
this low-level loathing for Jerry despite
wanting to stay in their marriage Summer's baby
Jerry Jr has been born I wonder if they're ever
going to reference that baby again in the future
too because they still have their space baby which
they've referenced several times this season
there's also a bit of a joke about that at the
end of the episode as well Morty worried about
what's going to happen to the new baby that
he's got growing inside of him is a way for the
writers to clown on themselves for actually doing
the space baby what about my beard and unborn
child let them go Rick and Morty references the
actual opening titles as they travel through the
season six opening titles which actually kind of
makes it so that these are all real scenes that's
always the joke like are these scenes real are
they fake scenes in the intro will we see them
in actual episodes but because you're seeing
them all through this episode technically we're
all in a season six episode even though in this
context some of the scenes are meant to be fake
events also when they pass through the butter
Morty scene Rick calls it their best episode
ever I think the bigger joke there is that we
might never actually see that episode happen like
the best episode ever is the one that they never
actually make and they finally get shocked when
they run through the actual titles themselves
when Morty questions whether or not they're fake
characters inside a TV show like I said normally
this would mean that he understands that but
because Rick spends so many different times in the
episode telling him to forget about it it'll just
confuse you I think means that he walks away from
this episode just being totally confused about
it and still thinking of himself as being a real
person inside a real Multiverse this also makes
me wonder if Prime rig is so evil like he's the
main antagonist because he also realizes that he's
a fake character in a TV show and nothing he does
ultimately matters which is why he doesn't really
seem to have any sense of morality which is what
makes him so dangerous because he realizes that
nothing matters because this is a fake TV show
when they put on the goggles to help them find
the actual fourth wall to break that points out a
number of Storytelling tropes like deus ex machina
chekhov's gun gratuitive violence foreshadowing
ticking clock action enhancer which are all real
life storytelling devices that TV movie writers
use to make episodes movies more interesting
which Rick also then calls out making fun of
the moonlight TV show with Bruce boss and civil
Shepherd talking about breaking the fourth wall
too much he's basically saying that the way that
he breaks the wall we can get the audience and he
actually looks at the screen breaking the fourth
wall in the way that he usually does addressing
us the audience in a more subtle way just doing it
every once in a while is the right way to do it in
the mood lighting TV show was famous for breaking
the fourth wall all the time getting super meta in
a way that he thinks was kind of hacky they use
a new type of Portal Device like the portal gun
to break the fourth wall literally and remember
this is supposed to be a layer of reality that
exists above their normal Third Dimension reality
the device that he uses to open that fourth wall
portal looks kind of like a television remote
because he's breaking out of the TV show with
it which is why from this place story Lord can
control all of their lesser reality it's full
of all kinds of Storytelling tropes like narrative
threads watershed moment escalation trials that's
one of the early references to Joseph Campbell's
hero's journey in the episode which they pay
off later when he's an actual character in the
episode all the Joseph Campbell's stuff is more
of a joke about Dan Harmon in real life also Dan
Harmon did a cameo scene as the Joseph Campbell
character if you don't know anything about Dan
Harmon in real life in real life he's famous for
using what he calls his story wheel which is
based on Joseph Campbell's hero's journey and
he just uses it to help himself write episodes
they use it all the time in the Rick and Morty
writers room he's been using it since before he
worked on the Community TV show there's an alien
that's designed to look just like him in real
life which is a writer himself which Rick and
Morty make fun of and he pushes the giant story
wheel around trying to suck motivation from all
of his characters so like I said a lot of the
episode is Dan Harmon making fun of himself the
other writers making fun of Dan Harmon saying that
he's a terrible writer Rick calls out TV critics
and Space Jam they actually did a cameo scene
in Space Jam which they just clown on in this
episode for being way too meta because the Space
Jam movie was terrible we're done running tests
on your Badger thing it turns out his condition is
irreversible I'll never erase what I saw from my
brain he's your problem now down done so Rick is
canonizing the Space Jam movie to Rick and Morty
like they actually had that as an adventure in
universe but he's also making fun of themselves
for actually doing that like I can't believe we
actually did that they bring back the same Jesus
from the story Train episode who's also voiced by
Christopher Maloney he also voiced him during the
story Train episode as well which is also meant
to foreshadow story Lord coming back voiced
by Paula Giamatti like he was during the story
Train episode Also earlier in the episode they
had a joke about the Trope of foreshadowing that's
literally what happens here and he just explains
what happened to them after the post-credits scene
in The Story train episode like they transcended
that layer of reality to become actually real
Morty references South Park's version of Jesus
canonizing South Park to Rick and Morty like it's
a show inside Rick and Morty now during that show
Jesus is real and interacts with all the other
characters he's friends with them they treat
him more like a superhero with power similar
to the powers Jesus has in the Bible but he's
more of a bro when Rick says Morty's South
Park reference keeps them creatively account
able it's also a reference to Rick and Morty
being compared to South Park in real life as
well as The Simpsons Dan Harmon and Justin Rowland
have talked about this in the past about how a lot
of times when they're coming up with ideas for
the episodes they have to be careful because a
lot of story ideas have already been used by
South Park or The Simpsons in fact the entire
premise of one of the South Park episodes early
on was Simpsons did it because so many story
ideas had already been done by The Simpsons when
South Park came along Rick references Bane from
the Batman comics when Jesus is about to break
his back in a similar manner probably one of
the most famous comics of my childhood that and
The Death of Superman story Lord also calls out
another Trope when he says their devs will become
based on real events because that is a device in
episodes and movies when you base plots on things
that actually happen in real life revealing that
his ultimate goal in controlling all of reality
is to achieve motivation as a character which
is them kind of clowning on themselves saying
that he was a bad character when they introduce
him in season four in that entire episode itself
was kind of stupid like the writer character who
created story Lord in the first place even
hates the episode we should never come up
with that idea it was terrible Rick and Morty
literally call out the writers for being lazy
forward your notes to my ass it needed to never
be pitched I did my job goombie the ice queen
the tickets Please guy they just bailed on it he
also calls out the unlikely Ally Trope which is
a story where villain usually turns eyes to help
the heroes which they pay off when previous Leon
uses his power to trap Jesus in a previously on
Loop of his own life this is Mary Magdalene who
was a hooker his mother's name was also Mary in
the Bible he meets his disciples we see him on
the cross remember they actually used a wooden
Pinocchio Jerry to crucify someone when Society
restarted and they went through similar ages of
evolution again this is just meant to be Jesus's
resurrection in the Bible after he was crucified
and then like the Rick and Morty previously on
starts to get weirder and weirder and the same
thing happens with Jesus is previously on where
he turns down Napoleon's offer for an alliance
he faces off against the Loch Ness monster and
fights Dracula he becomes a tech billionaire tries
to use his money to resurrect Mary Magdalene and
then tries to get a witch to remove his powers
successfully growing old and feeble and then
seeing a incarnated version of Mary who's become
a nurse the reference story Lord being a fictional
character in the story Train episode when he picks
up one of the actual toys from that episode going
to the remnants of the Citadel of Ricks where it
was constructed and the whole joke here is the
idea that the creation becoming pissed off at the
Creator but it's also meant to be a reference to
the fans of the show in real life getting pissed
off at Dan and Justin because of the way the
episodes go and he spends a lot of these scenes
making fun of Dan Harmon is this your office or
your apartment why does it smell like you sleep
here you're my Creator why are you pathetic when
he says the other Ricks in the Citadel wanted
to do a Canterbury Tales type of story that's
a Chaucer a reference like it's a real life book
Canterbury tells us a series of short Adventures
following different characters the poker game
episode of Batman is a real thing Batman the
Animated Series now Canon to Rick and Morty that
episode is called Almost got em where each of the
Batman villains describe an adventure where they
almost kill Batman also it should be noted that in
real life Kevin Conroy just passed away the voice
of that verse version of Batman one of the best
Batman of all time so quick moment of silence
for him we meet the self-referential six who
are like Rick and Morty's version of the god hand
from berserk mixed with the six Avengers and the
Justice League also the referential six a bit of a
Sinister Six reference as well from the Spider-Man
comics because they're meant to be characters
who are so powerful that they've transcended
to this layer of reality and now they all have
reality warping powers and their names are based
on different story tropes mislead flashback who's
kind of like their flash continuity air protagon
Nick like protagonist and Rhett Khan as in retcon
all their fight scenes here against them are also
direct references to the different tropes that
they each represent for instance when he fights
the continuity era character Rick pulls out the
anti-metafield capable of blocking their attacks
and he could have used it previously against
story Lord Jesus or previous Leon but didn't
like he just brought it out of nowhere flashback
causes them to flash back to the 2020 election
protago nick's Powers turned the nameless
guard into the main character and then it
turns into this funny 80s style Montage of his
life they even bring back the Loch Ness monster
for one of his adventures Mr twist powers are
the smash cut grenade which is a reference to
the editing technique that basically transitions
quickly between two completely different types of
scenes causing them to wind up in a cell and his
other power is introducing major twists in this
one being that Morty is the surprise sixth member
of their group which then they pay off when Morty
surprises him by setting off one of his grenades
helping them escape from the prison cell brecon's
power is retconning any kind of thing within
reality which they demonstrate when Morty tries
to change his name to Red instead of Brett and he
makes it reality it is and always has been Rhett
the joke here about sports is just that it's
completely different from normal types of TV
episodes like Rick and Morty that you write out
in a writer's room they also reveal when they're
freeing him from prison that Rick has worked with
him in the past like they've known each other for
a while so it makes you wonder what Rick used him
to retcon previously in reality my early theory is
that he tried to use him to retcon the death of
his version of Beth and his wife before he went
after Prime Rick but because they're still dead
it means that either didn't work or something else
happened to cause them to die again they bring
back the butter robot doing the same joke what
is my purpose which itself a callback is another
storytelling Trope and they kind of treat retcon
like their version of Dr Manhattan like he's
someone who's way more powerful than the rest of
the team Morty calls out the Trope of the unearned
twists with their deaths being imminent like this
is totally unearned and they're saved by actual
Joseph Campbell in a cameo scene from Dan Harmon
himself like I said meant to be a reference to
Dan Harmon's Devotion to the Joseph Campbell
storytelling wheel that is used for many many
years a lot of the things that Joseph Campbell
talks about in references are actual storytelling
tropes and things from Joseph Campbell's hero's
journey talking about the structure of actual
stories and they use a lot of these scenes for
Rick and Morty to take the piss out of him which
is them also kind of clowning on Dan Harmon like
Dan Harmon making fun of himself for his slavish
Devotion to the Joseph Campbell style of story
storytelling calling out the old man in the suit
Trope because Campbell's soup but also you know
Basketball Diaries Jack and the Beanstalk all
kinds of stories where old men were not seen
eating soup they have a joke about Joseph Campbell
secretly being addicted to a really really gross
websites like better wipe that browser history
also apparently gets super racist at night when
he gets super drunk who also references Back to
the Future that's also a joke about the origin of
Rick and Morty like the whole show is based around
the idea of Doc Brown and Marty originally the
short that Justin Roiland made before it became
a show was called Doc and Marty the liquor on the
desk being branded writer's courage is also just
a general joke about writers in real life saying
that most writers are alcoholics which they also
pay off when he gets super racist when they're
sleeping in the shed he also references Superman
but you also remember recently he just referenced
the Justice League Snyder cut which features all
the Justice League characters so technically all
the Justice League characters all those people
would be Canon to Rick and Morty behind them
on the wall there's a carving of the snake eating
its tail which is also meant to be be a reference
to the story cycle of Joseph Campbell's character
arcs they have the joke about the Montage because
it takes years to build her device Morty winds
up getting pregnant to help them complete the
device and like I said Morty asking about what's
going to happen to his child is a way for them
to sort of cloud on themselves again for never
really bringing back the space baby like they
keep referencing it during this season as a way to
joke about that like yeah when are we ever gonna
bring that back who knows they have another joke
about changing the actual show to be more like
season one episodes Rick getting super pissed off
also reference to Dan Harmon and Justin Roiland
in real life all the writers getting tired of
fans asking for them to do that I Want to Have
Fun Classic Rick and Morty Adventures like in the
old days then we'll get along fine fascist Morty
do some classic Adventures like season one when
they escape back to their lay of reality they pass
through the opening titles again and story Lord
uses the new device made of the story trains in
the Citadel to try and siphon off the motivation
of all the characters around the Multiverse when
he says greenlit obviously that's a reference to
the green of the energy but also that's another
television production term for when TV shows
or movies are approved and they actually start
production the Dan Harmon parody alien pushing
the wheel around to move is another joke about Dan
Harmon's Devotion to the story World device in his
writer's rooms creating episodes using the story
wheel is also another call back to that Joseph
Campbell joke about making the show more like it
was during season one with the Citadel of Ricks
in the central finite curve machine that evil
Morty wound up breaking love the random joke they
have about the worker who's so unmotivated that he
doesn't want to register to use the dirty website
Rick calling Jan a sweaty Rider and then him
telling Morty about only stopping for black belts
or big pairs of tits is Dan Harmon making fun of
himself calling himself a degenerate basically
winning references the one big successful thing
that he wrote he's talking about the Rick and
Morty show in real life they bring back the joke
about the gutters from the story Train episode and
old dudes who mysteriously have super ripped ABS
him not taking notes is also another reference
to writers in real life getting notes on their
stories from Executives at networks which they
also kind of pay off in the post-credits scene
too with a bunch of Executives from the network
like Adult Swim Executives running after the tag
character to try and stop him I think the joke
about the phone salesman at the mall is that
they're super pushy and won't take no for an
answer like they're way more motivated to cell
phones than Rick is to avoid being sold to phone
the whole thing about being picky about licensing
is another joke about Dan and Justin in real life
not being super picky about the merchandise that
Adult Swim makes for Rick and Morty because it
makes them so much extra money in real life which
they pay off later in the episode with a joke
about the new website that Rick calls out where
you can actually buy the plushies kind of like the
story Train episode where you could actually buy
the story train I love the more already stops the
writer by basically getting him to realize that
being a writer sucks and all creative people
are ultimately miserable in believing that the
best thing he could do would be to just quit
writing altogether the way he references the
Green Arrow spec script makes it sound like Dan
Harmon actually wrote that green arrow movie in
real life kind of wonder if we're ever going to
see that at some point the way they joke about
it his green arrow movie was pretty terrible
so I'm guessing we're not gonna see that they
referenced Mr Nimbus again who is a parody of
Namor which we just saw in the Black Panther
movie when he starts talking about hiatuses that's
also a reference to the real life break that they
just had between episode 6 and episode 7. the all
good things must come to an end line is also from
Star Trek the next generation's series finale
then the Callback joke about the website you
can visit is actually Rick Dash plush dot Biz
which is a real website that Adult Swim created
for this episode when you click on it it takes you
to Adult Swim's website but they created a special
page for it and just says you can't buy these
dolls in this reality the clickable button also
just takes you to the main streaming page for the
Rick and Morty episodes the other joke here about
burning this story wheeled device is Dan Harmon
in real life continuing to use his story well
in the writer's room because right after this the
writer goes back to the Citadel and comes up with
another bad idea that Joseph Campbell gets really
upset about like no no no this is a terrible idea
during the actual post-credits scene they have
another meta joke about the post-credits scene
in the tone of the rest of the episode where
they reveal another alien called tag man lives
and exists in the post-credit scenes of episodes
tag man also feels kind of like a visual reference
like his visual design looks kind of like the
Earl of Lemongrab from Adventure Time because
Justin Roiland also voiced that character him
killing all the people in the business suits
later also feels like a reference to him not
taking notes from The Adult Swim Executives if
he spotted any other Easter eggs or references in
the episode that it didn't talk about in the video
just write them in the comments below but like I
said it's meant to be an episode that specifically
calls out all the meta referential aspects of each
Rick and Morty episode so it was way over the top
in terms of Easter eggs and references my full
episode 8 video will post when it comes out next
week also a big reminder the Marvel Guardians
of the Galaxy holiday special is airing later
this week I'll be doing a bunch of videos for
that as well so be sure to enable alerts for
my channel so you don't miss that everyone click
here to learn about the secret Deadpool Christmas
movie Deadpool vs Santa Claus and click here for
my Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!